this video is brought to you by
skillshare
hey there internet people jared here
it's been years since dc unveiled their
expanded cinematic universe but
unfortunately these days
we can't think of batman or superman
without getting a little bit
sad or very very sad hello darkness my
old friend
so today we're gonna face that sadness
together and take a look at the big
question to end
all big questions what the hell went
wrong with the dceu
sure you can point to standalone
successes people seem to like aquaman
wonder woman was pretty good but unlike
marvel which managed to make over 20
movies with only a few stinkers dc's
grand ambitions
seem to have crashed and burned how
could such a sure thing turn out
so disappointing the way we see it the
problems can be traced back to two
comics from 1986
and the mismanaged influence they've had
on superhero culture at large
allow us to explain welcome to this
wisecrack edition on the dc eu
what went wrong and of course spoilers
ahead for all the films in the dceu as
well as slight spoilers for some
excellent comics
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
skillshare
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of inspiring
classes for creative and curious people
with skillshare you can explore new
skills and learn more about your
passions all from the comfort of your
own home
right now the world can seem very hectic
but channeling your energy into doing
something productive like learning a new
skill
can be a great way to relieve stress one
class i recommend
is everyday minimalism find common
creativity in simple living by aaron
boyle
it's the perfect class to take in these
times when everyone is trying to live
simply
cheaply and find a sense of calm while
being productive
aaron will teach you how to navigate
stressful situations and how to make the
best
with less not more each skillshare class
comes with a discussion board and
resources for you to complete
projects in tandem with the class it
feels great to focus on something that
isn't the news
and stay connected with the community of
people who will provide support and
encouragement
a premium annual membership is less than
ten dollars a month and right now the
first 1000 wisecrack fans to click the
link
in the description can get a 2 month
free trial and now
back to the show let's dive in now of
course the dceu
isn't over per se parts of it are even
getting rebooted with definite articles
such as the suicide squad and a highly
anticipated
the batman still at a time when
superhero franchises are the biggest
movies in the world
characters like cyborg flash and most
egregiously
superman have seemingly disappeared to
be fair it's not for lack of trying
but there were fundamental issues with
their plans from the very beginning
to make sense of those issues we first
need to understand superman and batman
and what they represent
two different versions of pure wish
fulfillment not only in terms of putting
on a cape and fighting crime which would
be awesome
but in terms of the way they make us
think about human potential superman in
all his god-like power reflects what we
wish we could be
he's by definition more than human he is
the fantasy of being freed from our
physical limitations batman on the other
hand
made himself who he is through drive
will
persistence and a sizable inheritance he
pushed himself to the absolute extremes
of human capability
in other words he's what we know we
could be if we applied ourselves and
maybe had a butler these two heroes also
differ greatly in their psychology
batman is irrevocably flawed no matter
how hard he tries or how many villains
he punches
he'll never get over the tragic death of
his parents and that's
led him on a personal crusade against
crime he is constantly engaged in the
struggle to do the right thing because
essentially there's not much separating
him from the villains he faces
the key way that he does distinguish
himself is in one clear unbreakable rule
he will not kill lest he become like the
mugger who murdered his parents
superman for all his unearthly power is
a rural farm boy at heart
he isn't driven by trauma he simply
believes that he has a moral and ethical
duty to use his power to help
he was raised to know that lying is
wrong that you shouldn't harm other
people and that honest work is more than
good enough
he doesn't generally involve himself in
geopolitics or governmental policy
because he doesn't see it as his place
he never uses more force
than is necessary at his core he
embodies everything good
and noble about the human spirit through
this he reinforces faith in our values
and provides
hope at least these are your standard
batman and superman
different artists have imagined superman
as a communist or batman as a vampire
but the way our two favorite superheroes
manifested in the dceu
as helmed by zack snyder can directly
trace their influence back to two
specific works that take a unique
approach to heroics
alan moore and dave gibbons watchmen and
frank miller's the dark knight returns
both of these comics were revolutionary
when they debuted in 1986 because they
subverted and deconstructed
so many superhero tropes by placing them
within a real world context
both watchmen and the dark knight
returns pick apart the kind of society
that would necessitate superheroes
and the kind of people that would be
drawn toward the superhero life they
critique the very
concepts of superheroics and vigilantism
as well as the effects that they would
have on the world
watchman took a wide view of the genre
as a whole using newly created
characters to represent the archetypes
present in superhero fiction the
comedian a stand-in for flag-wearing
patriotic heroes like captain america
gleefully quells social unrest and
commits atrocities in vietnam
can tend to be a tool for the government
the all-powerful dr manhattan mirrors
all the unimaginably powerful heroes
like superman
captain adam or silver surfer but
manhattan's ultimate power leads to an
increasing disconnect from the human
condition
thereby questioning the fundamental
humanity of this type of super being
which tacitly leads us to consider what
connects characters like superman to
people like us
and the kind of cold logic and greater
good mentality that characters like
batman so often fall into
also comes into question with ozymandias
squid-based master plan to unite the
world under a common enemy
by killing millions this brings the very
notion of heroism itself into question
pushing us to examine our own moral
concepts of justice and good
gadget-loving detectives obsessive
crusaders the legacy hero
all these archetypes and more are
expertly folded into a handful of
characters
however as we've seen more still treats
them as real people with complex
psychology
none of them are truly good or truly bad
whereas watchmen looks at the entire
genre the dark knight returns hones in
on a single figure batman it imagines a
much older caped crusader who has aged
in real time
eschewing the then unchallenged
convention of unaging comic book heroes
we see the batman robin dynamic in a new
light too with batman characterizing the
series of robins that have served him as
soldiers in this telling the death of
the second robin jason todd was the
biggest factor in batman's decision to
retire
but when he fails to quell as crime
fighting urges and dawns the cape and
cowl again
he is more than willing to take another
impressionable child under his wing
this directly addresses the inherent
irresponsibility of batman in regards to
enlisting children and teenagers into
his hyper-violent war on crime
miller also reappraises the mythic
perpetual struggle between batman and
the joker here the joker has been pretty
much comatose since batman retired
confined to arkham and seemingly
compliant but after batman returns to
gotham the joker too resurfaces to
continue their feud
miller paints their conflict as an
effect of batman's presence
suggesting that maybe it was batman
himself who caused crime to evolve into
super crime
and the stakes to be irreversibly raised
in gotham city miller also features
superman
as a naive ignorant yes man for the
government who wages a climactic battle
against batman
essentially because the president said
so overall watchmen and the dark knight
returns broke
new ground in the development of
superheroes and were heralded for their
self-aware critiques of the genre but as
revolutionary as they were
both books come to somewhat pessimistic
conclusions about superheroes put simply
they're grim grimy and hella cynical
they both feature the governmental
regulation and prohibition of
superheroes for example
suggesting that the natural response to
super beings would be military
application
and they both paint superheroes as
psychologically compromised
driven by neuroses and disorders
unfortunately the comics industry didn't
really get this
after the massive critical and
commercial success of watchmen in the
dark knight returns
everyone tripped over themselves to
mimic the grim dark aesthetic of these
two revolutionary works
but their imitation was only surface
level and led to what is known as the
dark age of comics
suddenly everything had to be dark and
gritty and superheroes turned into
holes who killed villains
indiscriminately optimism was seen to be
cheesy replaced with baseless angst
blood
gore and rampant over sexualization was
everywhere
but seemingly just for the aesthetic
without the nuance and complexity of
watchmen and the dark knight returns
the stories were ultimately hollow enter
zack snyder
before the dceu snyder was becoming
known as the comic book guy in hollywood
mostly due to his faithful adaptation of
watchmen and during the press for
watchmen snyder lauded two comics over
all
others watchmen duh and the dark knight
returns
even mentioning his desire to adapt the
latter for film
and here's where we get into the real
meat as to why the dceu fell flat on its
face
the same cynical deconstruction that
worked for watchmen and the dark knight
returns
seemed to inform every decision snyder
made when building the dceu
he could only see the superheroes and
the world they inhabit through a grimy
pessimistic lens
but just like the dark age of comics
snyder seemed preoccupied with the dark
surface
rather than the intellectual core
furthering this his overriding warship
of those fabled deconstructivist comics
caused big problems when he drew from
other
less gritty source material to highlight
this let's look at man of steel the
origin story for the granddaddy of all
superheroes
snyder actually draws from a lot of
influences here predominantly the
classic optimistic superman comics
birthright by mark wade and all star
superman by grant morrison the movie
wears these influences on its sleeve
things like clark flying alongside a
herd of zebra and the s crest on his
costume standing for hope that's what
this symbol means
symbol of the house of earl means hope
are pulled straight from birthright he
even lifts this speech almost word for
word from all-star superman you will
give the people of earth
an ideal to strive towards
they will race behind you they will
stumble
they will fall but in time
they will join you in the sun cow but
standards nods to these inspirations are
essentially lip service we get
acknowledgments by the way of shared
design
imagery and dialogue it's not an s
on my world it means hope but snyder
seemingly can't reconcile their hopeful
uplifting themes with his own cynicism
we know this because whenever possible
man of steel takes the dark and gritty
option we covered this in our what went
wrong for man of steel but between the
rampant collateral damage
and superman actively murdering zod at
the climax
man of steel doesn't look kindly upon
the big blue boy scout
the creative team has explained that the
intention was to have him eventually
grow
into the morally grounded superman we
know and love but
here's the problem snyder introduces the
character already subverted
his angst and general hand ringing
placing him closer to a reluctant hero
instead of the paragon of truth justice
and hope but superman is arguably the
archetypal superhero
you can't introduce a definitive
archetype and deconstruct that archetype
simultaneously
otherwise you're not introducing
superman you're introducing big
flying dude the proto-superman that we
see in man of steel
is ultimately so far from the superman
that we recognize
that he's a different character entirely
snyder gave us even more insight into
this choice in an interview
in which the journalist stated that the
so-called no win scenario is the only
way to test a hero's rules and ethics
snyder agreed adding that it's the only
way to move forward with the hero
because otherwise the hero drowns in the
mire of his own morality
according to this you can view the
climax of man of steel as the ultimate
moral and ethical
test except superman fails in
every conceivable way literally the
first metahuman superman has to deal
with causes him to lose
all focus allowing metropolis to be
leveled countless people to die
and superman becomes a murderer snyder's
superman doesn't even register that he
could do anything else other than snap
some necks this is a textbook example of
dark and gritty disguised as supposed
clever subversion
it's worth stating that at this point
snyder's plan to essentially build up to
a true superman was still viable we'd
only seen one movie after all
which brings us to batman v superman and
where the cracks really begin to show
see batman v superman was supposed to be
another superman film
a direct sequel to man of steel but then
snyder decided to add batman in there
and make miller's the dark knight
returns the central influence
batman v superman is notorious for being
a dumpster fire of a movie
and again we've covered it in its own
what went wrong but for this video let's
look at snyder's two main inspirations
the dark knight returns as mentioned and
the death of superman what snyder
chooses to take from them
and what he chooses to omit once again
demonstrate his fascination with
surface level gritty subversion the
first time we see them together on the
big screen we get a frankly psychotic
batman
killing goons branding people and
straight up premeditating the
cold-blooded murder of superman
and superman well he's just sort of
there perhaps presumably internally
struggling
in taking the surface level angst and
violence from the dark knight returns
but ignoring the deeper themes
snyder creates a contradiction in
character where as the dark knight
returns asks us to consider the
archetypal batman's relationship to
violence or robin
snyder simply wants us to consider how
cool it is that batman brands people
or put another way the dark knight
returns is in conversation with and
criticizes the established batman mythos
batman v superman on the other hand is
talking to itself
and it's mostly saying grit is good the
same issues apply to snyder's use of the
death of superman
which ironically could have helped
snyder build up his wholesome version of
the man of steel
released in the midst of the dark age of
comics the death of superman sees
superman die at the hands of doomsday
four separate heroes superboy steel
eradicator and cyborg superman
try to fill the hole that his death has
left in metropolis to
varying degrees of success but when a
bigger threat in the form of mongol
aided by none other than cyborg superman
appears to wreak havoc superman returns
from the dead
proving to be the only one who can stop
them and be worthy of the title of
superman thematically the whole story
revolves around the notion that a dark
and gritty superman isn't superman at
all the methods of the four replacement
superman
actually reflect the edgy grim heroes of
the 90s however the only thing snyder
takes away from this
is superman plus death rather than
seeing how superman's death could
fulfill his arc of redeeming him
snyder ignores everything else to once
again hyper focus
on the surface fact that superman done
died
by the time justice league rolled around
the damage had already been done
we pick up where snyder left off
superman's dead
batman's guilt written and struggling
with his violent tendencies and wonder
woman's oddly detached from
everything while we may never know the
entirety of snyder's plans what we do
know paints a somewhat conflicted
picture
on the one hand snyder's vision would
have revealed martian manhunter and
green
lantern completing the iconic justice
league lineup facing off against
darkseid which makes it hard not to pine
for what could have been
but on the other hand even more time
would have been spent in the nightmare
future
with a decimated justice league fighting
back against a brainwashed
fascist superman that part would have
been inspired by tom taylor and brian
buchelado's injustice comics
a grim gritty and cynical deconstructive
tale that asks
what if superman broke bad based on
snyder's previous adaptations it's not
hard to extrapolate
we suspect the same kind of surface
level cynical interpretation would have
come into effect here too
but ultimately we can't know for sure
because snyder didn't get to complete
his vision
and we'll never really know if his
controversial choices would have paid
off
still the fact remains that we did get
most of the story and most of us hated
it
so much so that it killed the idea of an
interconnected cinematic universe
dead it's not all doom and gloom though
dc and warner brothers have stepped back
from their sprawling plans of
connectivity
handing the reins over to a creative
team that are willing to embrace the
bright
playful and hopeful nature of the genre
wonder woman aquaman and shazam
have generated warmer reception from
fans and critics alike
and indicate a less depressing future
for dc films
but what do you think wisecrack did
snyder miss the point
or are we being too hard on the guy let
us know what you think in the comments
thanks to our dope patrons for
supporting the channel and our podcasts
slam that subscribe button and as always
thanks for watching guys
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you